silence is directed by Martin Scorsese
and stars Andrew Garfield Adam driver
and Liam Neeson and is the story of two
priests who travel to Japan searching
for father Ferreira played by Liam
Neeson they've gotten word that father
Ferreira has denounced the Christian
faith in public and they traveled to
Japan to try to figure out if that's
true if father Ferreira is still alive
and if they can help any other Japanese
who are also trying to believe in
Christianity well under a lot of
persecution for their beliefs any time
Martin Scorsese directs a film I'm there
if you wanted to ask me who's somebody
who's been around for a long time who's
been making great films who still has it
who rarely ever has a misstep who still
to this day makes excellent classic
level films and even though I love
Steven Spielberg Martin Scorsese doesn't
just make a movie like The BFG an OK
children's family film
even when Scorsese gets his hands on a
family film he makes Hugo which is great
Scorsese is one of the last remaining
directors who has continued to make
fantastic films into his 70s and silence
proves that beyond the shadow of a doubt
this is a staggering film I struggled
watching this at times and not because
it's boring or because it's very long
and it is because this is an emotionally
gutting film and this is coming from
somebody who doesn't necessarily follow
any specific religion in a devout way
that didn't have an impact on me as I
watch this film so if you feel that you
might not enjoy the film as much since
you don't adhere to any specific belief
structure well then I feel like like
myself you're gonna relate to this movie
on the level of these are people who
believe what they believe and they're so
hardened in their beliefs that they're
not going to let anything get in the way
of that no matter what stands in their
way and so this film is incredibly
powerful in its examination of what
someone would go through when they are
undergoing a crisis of faith and our
lead character played by Andrew Garfield
most definitely does we see him go to
the lowest of lows
emotionally when we start out with him
he's at a ten he has the utmost faith
you could possibly have in God and by
the end of this film you are looking at
a battered person who has had everything
stripped away from him emotionally
and it's not just the fact that he's so
good in this movie which my god he is
Scorsese directs the shit out of this
movie this film is gorgeous its lens by
the same cinematographer that helmed the
wolf of Wall Street and they're pairing
in this film is a thing of beauty if you
love examining the way films are shot
this is one of Martin Scorsese's
best-looking films I think and the most
remarkable part of that is that he's
working with very small confined
environments a lot of the film takes
place where the characters are in
captivity or going through some very
rural area or having to survive in a
small tiny Hut and the fact that this
film looks as good as it does is a
testament to this incredible pairing of
director and cinematographer Andrew
Garfield and Adam driver both are
fantastic in this film but once again
this is another award worthy performance
from Andrew Garfield and a year filled
with really good performances but this
and Hacksaw Ridge proved to me that
social network was not a fluke Andrew
Garfield is a fantastic actor and he
once again shines in this movie as does
Liam Neeson he does not have a huge role
in this film he's definitely of a
supporting nature but his role is very
complex which leads me to my favorite
part of silence and that is its
complexity this is a film that Scorsese
has said he has wanted to make for a few
decades and according to him in his
humbleness he just wasn't there yet he
didn't feel he had the skill to pull
this film off it's a story that in
gut-wrenching ways examines how a group
of people were so brutally violated
through their faith to try to denounce
said faith in public and when the film
ended I took this humongous breath and I
felt like I hadn't really taken a breath
that big throughout the entire runtime
of the film because I was so laser
focused on every shot it's perfectly
edited fantastically acted beautifully
directed extremely
written this is as I said an emotionally
staggering film and I think one of
Scorsese's best it's incredibly
difficult and it is a frustrating movie
and as I said it's complex but these are
all feelings that I imagine one would go
through when dealing with an extreme
crisis of faith and so I think that is
actually a perfect reaction to be having
when you watch a film like silence and
for that reason I'm gonna give silence
an A+ this is an extremely
unconventional movie that a lot of
audience members will probably hate just
like general audience members didn't
like the wolf of Wall Street they're
probably going to have the same reaction
of this movie because it's
intellectually challenging and it
actually is faith challenging as well
which is really really hard to come by
I'm so glad that we still have people
like Scorsese out there making films
like this that are so against the
Hollywood norm and these are the types
of films that I think people who really
love film should be supporting guys
thank you so much as always for watching
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]